mmm some extra clamps i like that that
guy thanks for thorough dude
a little different than how you boys
doing at playgroup yeah bang one clap
you got a squad though yeah yeah but
y'all got a squad too yeah yeah we got
people talking y'all got we got four
here and then you got three behind the
camera
but also you like you have multiple
people talking i feel like they're
talking and working yeah yeah crazy
computer chin doesn't audio on video
yeah and then the talent
they have like miles
is the homie and he switches angles and
then he talks and then miles is the
producer and he talks very rarely but
then you also have dove on there yeah
yeah but he's on there and then
when uh schultz did flagrant two here i
was arguing with dove because he's
saying how they save money on hotels and
[ __ ] like that yeah which i pride myself
on that stuff so me and him we're
arguing airbnbs or hotels you're airbnb
airbnb all day but that's all you also
rent out airbnb so you know you're
making money correct yeah yeah i'm i
like a hotel i hate hotels especially
pandemic i love how impersonal they are
i love how sterile they are i don't have
to [ __ ] talk to i don't even make the
[ __ ] like you gotta fix airbnb when you
leave [ __ ] you yeah
i don't want to make my bed
they just want you to take out the trash
use this trash oh eat my ass
take out the trash for me
but then also in atlanta we had this
airbnb where they had a camera set up
and they're like literally no more than
eight people like if
[ __ ] you
past eight we're gonna start finding you
and i told my brother like we can write
who the hell we want how would they know
and jay's like look at the cameraman
yeah wild jesus yeah super aggressive
those people should not have an airbnb
yeah but you also shouldn't have a
camera in the [ __ ] house i i know
it's outside which i wow like
like it was you know buckhead so it's
like a super nice area so i mean i mean
we me and my girl rented an airbnb in
arizona and the woman she's so nice he
just had you know
she had some christian things up on the
thing and i was like okay you know fair
enough very related
but it's all very very nice and showed
us everything and there was a garage
right next door and i'm we're hanging
out and we're talking and doing our
thing and i hear a phone ring
like it's and i go where's
hello is your phone on and she goes no i
go what and then i hear
i hear like
ruffling
and i go
and the door has
it's got it's like it's that it's like
high waters that high off the ground
well she's in the garage that's her
office and she's just there's a bed
behind a door you know the kind of door
that's hollow that you can put your
finger through yeah yeah that's where
she's living
and i went oh no
that's a problem but we but we had that
we had that in austin when we stayed in
austin it was this dope house and there
was like this american awesome we did
vulcan the whole crew was there we were
like that suburb so is this dope is that
indians right right right but they
straight up that house this is it's just
like that's their house yeah so what
happened yeah straight up their home
yeah i would never rent from indians and
i'm i'm the indian support indian guy
but you've never lived but i'm not i'm
not really this hustle so we looked her
up she's a doctor
bro they're going to make money they the
best at making money even better than
jews i think dude
there's an argument for that yes but
dude what they did is this is their
family house they had kids and
everything so we walk in they have
family pictures on them everywhere in
the kid's room he had money in the piggy
bank oh yeah dude they still had their
prescriptions in like the refrigerator
but then they had a a secondary house in
the backyard
and i'm looking and i see lights on with
the family was like oh we rented get
your [ __ ] let's go to the back
so you're just like sleeping in their
bed and [ __ ] i used to airbnb my room in
new york i had a bedroom and then when i
my wife now we were dating for like less
than a year there were nights where i
was like yo we can't stay at my place
she lived in philly i lived in new york
like we got to go to philly or do
something because there's two people in
our room right now yeah his daddy's
making 175 dollars yeah 100
000 a night dude it's new york i'm a
block from times square it's good yeah
this is prime real estate these guys
and i wouldn't rent to another indian
because i know i'm do i'm [ __ ] you
over i can't do this out of love i love
love yeah
people only you're just entrepreneurial
there's an article there's an
dude that's all entrepreneurial is
typically culturally if you're indian
from what i've seen you have you have a
choice it's like you can be either a
doctor or a lawyer or an engineer yeah
it's weirdly i think doctor engineer
lawyer i think nigerians are the same
way
most immigrant parents are like that
yeah for sure especially from other
continents like mexico you come here
make your [ __ ] way however you can if
you're coming from another continent it
was probably such a pain in the ass to
get here yeah that it's like the best of
the best education wise and then they're
like well that's how we got here so
that's what you're going to do oh chance
parents want to be a goddamn doctor i'm
sure jen are they disappointed you work
with my dumbass or what they don't know
what we do they don't know podcasting
yeah yeah yeah they don't they don't
think of it as like any anything they
think it's radio for poor koreans 100
percent really
yeah yeah you know my dad my brother
went to uh lunch with my dad the other
day and some guy comes up you know and
uh
i guess he works out my dad or something
he goes how's your son doing cause i
bought years ago i bought an m6 from
this guy and he's like how's your son
doing my dad's like you he seems to be
doing good out in l.a you know and he's
my dad goes he's in hollywood so he's
doing that and he goes what exactly you
doing my dad goes you know i think he's
like one of those social media
influencers
hey dad hey
are you [ __ ] me god damn it now this
is the same dad after i shot my first
restaurant on show time after doing
comedy for two weeks yeah i got a
showtime special after my no no my
family members come to taping that's
cool next day after i shoot i get a call
from my dad how'd your speech go
shut up
i felt like i felt like crying
my parents did the same my mother did
the same thing i'm on a tv show i'm on a
tv show every week and she goes how's
your skit going
and now is this the same thing as the
comedy i go this is [ __ ] tv
like i i've worked so hard to get can
can i get a little acknowledgement i
flew my dead out the because you know
he's a huge car guy when i bought my
ferrari i flew them out to drive when
they sand they go pick it up they have a
bow all over and he's like man it's
crazy it's instagram
instagram
instagram no clue these guys snapchat
stories must be insane
i mean your only fans is list
because
you're not in on the world of social
media or podcasts my dad just discovered
podcast loves them now but i was like my
dad my dad pays attention to everything
i do well it's more of a recent
relationship between us but that is the
blackest thing i have ever heard well
hold on l.a
hold on his dad's trying to make up for
lost time oh yeah again again he did 17
years in prison
you just got blacker
i don't know how you did it but you just
didn't
he didn't do the crime either so oh even
black guy
he's just giving black
oh are you serious yeah yeah oh my god
you're like a real blind side yeah yeah
yeah were you having a cheerleading
seriously i was a cheerleader you're a
cheerleader yeah that's a disappointment
for that white family they're like
they're getting a [ __ ] lie
i'm in there like oh i bet he's [ __ ]
i bet he's the size of me
i bet he runs a 4-4 in the 40s i bet
that vertical's insane we can give him
the football i bet first round draft
pick and they see you doing [ __ ]
tumbling in the backyard they see you on
season two a cheer like really
this is what we sacrificed for yeah
there you go these we got the adopted
black kids
they don't have any clue of what i do
either it's even now they don't even
know like even when they didn't they see
performing phoenix and [ __ ] or no yeah
but they don't look at it they look at
it as like oh wow that's amazing it's a
hobby right yeah that's what i think
parents think until you make money money
they're like this is a hobby that's cool
grow up exactly it's better than having
a trophy trophy parent like a trophy dad
i watch these uh when my daughter plays
tennis and i watch this oh asian family
that's different those kids play i'm
telling you they're they play four hours
a day and they're they're young yeah i
literally go i'm gonna burn them out i
know and also like your body i can't
believe that would be good for your
knees and yeah but i'm 38. hey pops
that's i'm all set
a little [ __ ] i'm on your boy he's
crushing it come on man be cool man yeah
do you think if you bought him a ferrari
he would be like all right i guess guys
no no no i think his dad's such an alpha
that he always he still looks at you as
his like his boy maybe he doesn't want
to accept it because he's such an alpha
that his son is out here shining hard
there's some there's his dad's super
smart and he's a successful guy but he's
also like a big kind of big guy and he's
i always get the sense that you guys
he's a competitive dude your dad
yeah he's not a i don't know how uh how
many podcasts have you done to promote
your special which is on youtube if you
guys haven't seen it outside what are
you at one point four million four i
think yeah i think one point four twenty
minutes twenty minutes special 20-minute
special called bring back a pool we hit
a million and a half hours in a week
yeah thank you guys so much man thank
you guys yo brendan was texting me the
whole time like helping me promote all
that [ __ ] he was texting me when it was
late like yo what the [ __ ] is going on
i'm trying to promote your [ __ ] because
i was like hey send it to me man so i
can bl so my team can blast out let me
know what you want to do and then he's
like yeah it goes live whatever and then
i don't even know you know i don't know
and then my guy's like hey it's not up
yet it was not touching like dude where
the [ __ ]
was that he was like i was losing
man so we had it i thought ready and
then i andrew was like yo i have four
hours from 12 p.m to 4 p.m the day
before the special comes out come let me
see it and i'll help you out could you
have hit could you could you have done
this two weeks dude
i know the guy's so busy so when he has
time you're like cool thank you so much
and to his credit man he stayed he said
12 to 4 p.m he stayed up with us till
4am and then he showed us on one joke
how many like just how many ways we get
elevated and then when we saw that joke
versus the way we had it we were like yo
we have to do this
just the way he edited everything the
way he's like just he just thinks of
ways to elevate he's like you see his
focus man like he's helping nobody's
better legitimately he would tell my guy
kevin who filmed everything and edit it
he'd be like kevin when i snap i need
you to make a cut and you just walk like
this and then go
and if kevin was the second light he'd
be like kev running back we gotta do it
again
[ __ ] amazing amazing then so we
stayed up from that 4 a.m the next three
days i think we slept like an hour a
night trying to get it done and we got
it went live was supposed to go
wednesday at like 12 p.m yeah friday at
5 00 p.m we were finished and we
uploaded as fast as worth it i think it
helped i think in a weird way i think it
helped the hype because we all blasted
it out and people are waiting waiting
away yeah and then when they fight
yeah well i was part of me deep down was
like this is cool because i'm getting
legit hundreds of comments on instagram
hundreds of tweets messages people being
like where the [ __ ] is this special i'm
about to lose hope i'm about to just
give up completely but i'm freaking out
but also deep down i'm like that's cool
that people are cool yeah because they
want it it's a good thing but you're
also in the moment like i'm letting
everyone down why 20 minutes
we i just wanted to put out my goal with
this actually was
indians typically don't [ __ ] with you
until you get mainstream acceptance once
you do it true they're the most on board
people that's historically what i've
seen outside of russell aziz indians got
super into his ease after
uh funny people and tv show was it parks
and rec
uh same thing with like a few other guys
you would see they get a netflix special
and then indians are like that's our guy
yeah i don't the industry didn't really
[ __ ] with me because i guess i'm kind of
not saying things that are like things
they want to hear from minorities but
when you say indian like so so is there
a difference between people in india for
example like in mumbai versus like the
like expats who are here oh the indians
in india see me as completely american
yes they and that they have their own
comics from what i hear and they and
they're funny
there's some bad [ __ ] out there
for sure yes but they see me as like oh
he's indian american they kind of see a
little bit of similarity but he's
american but schultz is a fan base and
like your fan base on flagrant too which
is huge they [ __ ] with you right now
they [ __ ] with it's not heavy ending
there's indians that come just because
they see me uh and that's cool and they
see themselves represented in not a way
that you know it's kind of like whatever
to them a little bit too liberal or
whatever i'm not a conservative guy but
i'm also not the most liberal so they're
like oh that's cool to see somebody
moderate or whatever yeah but they also
i think for a long time saw me as just
like schultz's guy and this year is like
and i didn't get any i couldn't i was
selling shop i didn't get to headline
comedy clubs until a year ago so i grew
a ton in the past year and this is my
year i want to let [ __ ] know
like no i'm i'm here let's go that's
dope but you guys so 20 minutes is is
what that that's so it was it was this
way to get there i oh i had this idea of
like the bring back a poo idea was like
i hear a lot of yo like again black
people have been systematically i said
isn't special [ __ ] over for centuries
in america but a lot of other groups who
aren't nearly as oppressed you go
through some racism for sure but you're
trying to make it like you're oppressed
and you're not
like you are blessed to be here my
family in india
my dad's side got money my mom's side's
[ __ ] poor dude we sat in a house with
no electricity everybody like in the
whole village just talking that's a
night my cousins are studying [ __ ]
math with a lantern no [ __ ] so it's like
you're telling me you're oppressed and
you're here in a two-story house go [ __ ]
yourself man like cut that [ __ ] out
privileged american and i think a lot of
indians feel like me i was going to say
this
i think
more of them do i think i know my people
pretty well i still do my best to like
keep in touch with what my people are
feeling and my friends are you know my
indian friends i never lost touch with
whatever and i think all of us kind of
felt the same way but there are others
who don't you know there's a thomas soul
who's a black scholar talks about this a
lot he talks about he compares like uh
nigerians
um west indians you know of the black
experience from other cultures all that
and it's the same thing as they come
here and they're like
there's not even time to think about the
other stuff they're the first thing is
your kids got to get an education
whatever i got to do i don't work 16
jobs and you're going to get you're
going to be an engineer you're going to
be you know and that that seems to be
sort of the overwhelming drive it's not
even thinking about
racism because they're [ __ ] so busy
yeah
yeah
africans go hard on black people yeah
yeah they don't respect you but they
also don't get it they are thinking i
came from nothing yes but they don't get
and i didn't get it perspective like i
mean i understand how they got there you
know but i mean they they go hard i
don't know my issue is this and i want
to hear from both of you about this
because as a white dude i'm just me too
or no no no i'm saying but they're
they're black and i know but you know
it's tough for me
i'm a
full-blown americans
you're right
you are you are a native native american
cherokee i truly believe that you are
thank you but
i think so much of the talk on racism
okay
so [ __ ] you know i think all the
stocks are like just take the rogan
thing about how you can never say the
word no matter what are there any kind i
agree you know what i think i think
that's dishonest i think it's actually
dishonest the way most people on the
left talk about racism being a problem
is not only dishonest their targets
aren't racist and their their energy
directed at people like rogan or in
general or in general at finding tweets
that were seven you know years old 10
years old to prove that someone is a
racist they're they're not only
dishonest they're all they're they're
unreasonable they're dishonest and they
do absolutely nothing they're not going
out
they're not going after the right people
but they do nothing brian's yelling at
us i know right but it's true but like
my biggest problem and i don't know if
you feel this as well hey but you get to
speak first though yeah i mean you got
that i want joy my biggest problem is
like i hate this
where i'm like i'm i'm supposed to be a
victim right right and i'm not a victim
oh sorry sorry i'm not i'm not a victim
like
you know
it it's insane like it's mainly coming
from like woke white people i'm being
honest like i had a friend that was like
you know that sat down with me a friend
i've known for years
she lived out here recently no this was
like when i first moved to l.a and we
were catching up and she was and she
like i don't found this new perspective
of life you know she's from arizona as
well clearly a white cheerleader yeah
yeah yeah come on now
and she sat there and she was you know
you know like hey you know how you doing
like as if there was like this like
movement type thing that i'm supposed to
be a part of with her and she was like
you know you know it's okay for you to
say i [ __ ] hate white people and
she's white so like having this
conversation hate that [ __ ]
like it pissed me off she's not like
though huh was she hot no
brandon no no
no she's realistically hot yeah but no
realistically hot girl even has the
awareness yeah
yeah she's hot missing the whole point
oh yeah no that's a big point that's
always a point yeah but no i feel like
this but like
hearing that and then realizing like yo
i was i was adopted by white people and
i don't think that was i don't think
that messed up my life in any way i
don't think it took anything away from
like understanding who i am yeah as a
person and where i come from so like to
hear those kind of things it's like it's
it's just annoying because she feels
like she's doing the right thing she's
not bless her heart she's like those are
ours
she sounds like she's a little bit lost
misinformed and she's live not that
smart you know bless her heart like i
mean she's still my friend today yeah
but but it was just so aggressive and
it's just superb but yeah and i don't
know
leave my friends alone
but i mean
you know
you have to have a similar nah my thing
is
and this is what my issue is with a lot
of this like the industry [ __ ] from
brown people and my kind of brown people
is like it's a lot of like feel sorry
for me type of [ __ ] and it's like don't
tell me you have pride and you want pity
because those two things are
antithetical if i have pride i don't
want your [ __ ] pity i don't want your
[ __ ] charity i don't want your
[ __ ] pandering yeah don't talk to me
about that i know how hard it is talk to
me like a person don't i'm not a [ __ ]
charity case bro let's have a
conversation as human beings and
conservatives
tend to be better at that than liberals
liberals are [ __ ] falling all over
themselves to be hey i get it and that's
cool to say once i guess like yo it must
be rough for your family back don't you
think so how did you find that
perspective
like where did you find i think that was
ra my mom is very much like
she's coddles me a lot but also there's
no like if you fail it's your fault man
like there's no [ __ ]
but that's that's that's a classic
example i feel like conservatives
liberals have one narrative which is the
only reason that things are bad for
people of color
is because of racism systemic racism and
that's the end of the argument right
you're a victim and it's white supremacy
that does it instead of and i think the
conservatives have always said hold on
man there are a lot of examples
especially immigrant examples of people
who are black or indian who are asian
who who
took culture they had certain cultural
practices and certain beliefs that
enabled them to get ahead regardless of
that prejudice and so you got to bring
culture into it you got to be how
someone is raised the value systems when
you do that on college campuses if you
do that you get boot off [ __ ] stage
that's my problem it's just not honest
well like you know when i when i think
about you know my mom like you know
before the white family like you know we
went through crazy [ __ ] you know my
stepfather was a [ __ ] tyrant in the
house but i never saw her ever play
victim she always went to work on time
she made sure we always had food clothes
and she was the bread maker you know
what i mean he wasn't getting my mom you
know what i'm saying like she's a
[ __ ] a beast but like you know like
she never made me feel like like her
like a victim like we're victims like
we're
not sorry for you no and even with
reconnecting with my biological father
17 years in prison yeah uh
even we're connecting with him like he
doesn't feel like he's a victim
of anything like he knows what he did
you know what i mean like he served he
served his time but also like he doesn't
roll around with like a
victim mentality
like we can't do like he got his rights
back right that man fought to get his
rights back right which is like really
yes which is really [ __ ] hard
you know being a [ __ ] uh felon
even if even if you are a victim all you
have is sympathy to rely on that's not
going to help you my problem with even
if you embrace the narrative even if you
are a victim some people are victims of
doubt
yeah it it still doesn't help you get
out of your sympathy from other people
is not going to help you get out of your
[ __ ] situation yeah there's got to be
a middle ground where it's like look
look i used to very much
compartmentalize everything and when my
black friends be like dog my parents
made it from a poor place blah blah blah
okay that's too childish you can be
open-minded and say okay no i can see
our systematic races and [ __ ] black
people for a long time but that's it i
acknowledge that and now i can't pity
you and act like for the rest of our
relationship if i'm looking at you like
oh it must have been so hard that's not
authentic oh my god we're not friends
i can understand that's what happens and
then not and then not treat you like you
[ __ ] deserve anything different from
me than you're a human being like if you
two talk to me that way oh my god i
would go [ __ ] crazy ah i should make
fun of your pants hey [ __ ] you man
hey that's where i drop online
no no it's very clear you gotta adopt a
wife
from your shoes
would you say on on a daily basis
chappelle has it's his style someone
thought these were snowboarding pants
i'm like [ __ ] you no this is like japan
those are bruce lee's man
yeah i don't think it's you either i
don't know what the shoes are doing
necessarily are you are you into uh are
you into dope kicks are you into shoes
sort of but i'm also i'm 37 so i'm not
like in touch with what's hit but i'm
wearing jordan's cool when i was 37 37.
that's what was cool when i was school
in new york
no i was school in texas i'm from dallas
oh you are yeah i want to raise and i
think that's where i was like when i
grew up in texas i was like man there's
so many dumb conservatives here and i
was kind of more liberal and then i
moved to new york in la and i saw dumb
liberals and i was like y'all that's
just as bad
and more condescending so now i'm like
finally in a place where i'm like oh i
think i'm moderately you should go
special in texas shot the special in all
places where i've lived new york new
jersey and
uh houston my parents live in houston
now oh they just fall down some money in
houston huh it's a real [ __ ] and then
you you and you and you and schultz go
way back chelsea and i i met my first
week in new york so i started comedy in
la and everybody told me you go to
wherever just some open mics and [ __ ]
like that and uh everybody told me you
did a bag or black vets in particular
would say black veterans would be like
you did this backwards you go to la to
get famous you go to new york to get
good and i knew i wanted to be great at
stand up before anything so i was like
let me go to new york and how old are
you at this time 24 25 maybe i think i
just turned 25 and then i met andrew my
first week at some hood show in brooklyn
and again i'm a kid from texas i don't
know fashion so i see this kid coming up
to me wearing skinny jeans and he got a
mohawk and i'm like look at this gay
yeah yeah [ __ ] i didn't know
skinny jeans was fashion i was like this
guy but he's at this hood or i'm in
brooklyn so i'm like
there must be something to this guy and
then he offered me a ride back because
the show got canceled and we just
started talking comedy and he knew every
comic he liked i liked every bit he
liked i like yeah and then for a year i
would go do hood rooms and bomb my ass
off and he was at this place called the
village lantern where you would legit
take people off the street and do shows
and i hung out there a couple times i
always had fun with him and then i was
literally thinking about leaving new
york and going back to l.a but i was
like let me give new york one more
chance and hang out with these guys at
this crew andrew and them i like that
spot i like the vibe and then andrew and
i just like
comedy we were just on such a similar
wavelength and what we wanted to do and
the stuff we thought was funny that we
just kind of became very close and we
both are like very loyal and it just
grew from there that's cool
was it weird for you because andrew just
went from zero to a [ __ ] hundred and
was always so funny so fast that i kind
of my ego was checked very early where
it's like dude this guy is undeniably
funny right now and so i also i was
telling you i went through a lot of
years of being real angry and my i can
be very negative and like i worked
really hard on that and that kind of
helped me that he got so funny so fast
and i see how loyal he is to me i was
like yo i can never
be jealous of this man no i can feel
insecure and that's okay and be like man
when is my time gonna come but i can
never begrudge this dude who works his
ass off and is successful and is nothing
but a good friend i have to make sure i
always celebrate this guy's success yeah
and i've been good about checking myself
and being like yo let's ride together
you're my guy god bless you and that i
think was very helpful actually that
makes sense i wasn't doing the hood
rooms at first i bombed my ass off many
times yeah have you ever done hooded
rooms yes
yes
a lot in new york i know yeah especially
at the new york comedy club so yeah
that's not a good room that's a club
we're talking about dude you got no idea
oh yeah you're really you guys are young
you guys are young i mean i'm talking
about gun hill road i'm doing shows on
gun yeah well you know what okay so you
come to new york comedy club in 1992 93.
god you're old never mind
that's what i was saying so you got a
real [ __ ]
argument i was eight dude and i'm old i
know dude
and then doing stuff in actually in la
too and also in when i first got out
here but you also the open mics in new
york you would just find yourself
somewhere in brooklyn or whatever and
that would be
dude i told a [ __ ] penguin joke and
black room dude
all black room and i remember i was like
what's it like to be reborn a legless
flightless bird in the middle of the
south pole
and i'm doing this
it was tuesday i almost quit comedy i
almost quit comedy this woman goes like
this i never got this woman goes this
in the back she goes it got quiet and
she goes uh-oh
and it got worse from there i got off
stage and i was like i don't think
comedy's for me you know but i had to do
that i had
you had to commit to no because when you
do a an all-black room or even like it
would always be that or they'd have like
um uh they'd have uh like puerto rican
you know or like latin night and stuff
like that but you'd always find your way
in i'd always you know i knew people you
know but man you that's when i realized
you have to you there is such a
difference in back especially before the
internet there were huge differences in
demographics yeah huge like by the way
the jokes that worked in new york city
did not work in la i'm telling you it
was such a different mindset so really
yes because we didn't have the internet
so nobody was trained in ideas yeah
cultures cultures were so those lines
were [ __ ] so true it was so strong
yeah so if you got up and you tried to
do the [ __ ] that worked um and again
with a white audience that's young you
ate all the dishes i know i meant to ask
you you you did what you're on while in
out yeah yeah yeah i love while it out
let's take a little break from chatting
with akash let's take a little break can
we do that well yeah let's take a break
and take a break for yourself just
breathe for a second and think about
your body are you getting enough greens
that's a good question are you on a diet
athletic do you want to be athletic do
you want to be is your mom out of shape
is your stepmom out of shape you know
what i'm saying your brother yeah i'm
about athletic dude thank you for asking
brian because one tate scoop of ag-1
contains 75 vitamins minerals whole
foods source ingredients including a
multivitamin i don't care what diet
you're on you need this in your life
dude eight ounces of water i put that
ag-1 in boom instantly general
probiotics green superfood blend more in
one convenient daily serving than you
can get you know from your fruits and
vegetables dude forget pills so it's
talking about delicious drink man and to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you an immune supporting free one
year supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase if
you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give a g one a try
b we're busy dude i'm busy we're busy
sometimes bro
i'm not driving off dude especially when
i want to get a snack midnight snack or
i'm watching my favorite show and i want
to get old
when i'm craving something i'm like dude
i need this right now and our friends at
grubhub they said you know what
say less we got you covered for whatever
you need man we got you freaking covered
we got you whatever you need man from
extras to essentials grub hub now
delivers all your go-to convenience
items all day long not just food no dude
convenience store grub hub goods that's
right they're grub hub goods whether
it's a late night snacky a paper towel
maybe just one can of soda convenience
items delivered right to your door just
in the nick of the time so you don't
have to leave your home stay in your
underoos all right order your
convenience items from grubhub goods on
the app or online app is easier app is
easier yeah i love wylo now the top to
bottom most talented cast i've ever been
a part of in my life not so sweet but
you were on there how long ago i was on
there seven eight years ago probably it
was i was on there
i wasn't i wasn't gifted at it dude
these kids they were legit they got some
talent legit they would just make up a
song and i'm a [ __ ] is it all improv
on the spot yeah dude
you'll do boot camps where you like run
this [ __ ] forward and backward and
they'll be like yo we need a song uh
this game about take mary had a little
lamb and make this about uh riding the
bus yeah or whatever they're so good and
there we go so my head i was like there
has to be some production where they do
go over this they they probably have a
base to work off of my guess is that
they do a lot of that they do a lot of
rapping and they have they have their
forms that they add [ __ ] into rapping
yeah
they always if you're doing a song there
better be a [ __ ] rap verse in it yeah
yeah and but they start with some [ __ ]
that they can work off of yeah you play
the games you practice everything over
and over and over so they have you all
pre like y'all practice like just
getting ready for yeah like rehearse or
whatever yeah one hundred way like an
improv troupe you had to audition for
that show yeah and then you like here we
go
weirdly here i come yeah yeah yeah when
i got on that and i didn't realize the
way hollywood looks at and this is part
of the same thing i was talking about
the way hollywood looks at black people
is like
we can only market the safe black people
you have to make a room full of white
people comfortable because you guys know
85 south podcast yeah they're the huge
they're the most talented three people
and i say that in podcasts with three
people or four people yeah the most
talented three people in podcasting huge
they're insane carlos miller is maybe
the funniest human in america oh my god
dc young why is good at everything
chico beans a [ __ ] workhorse and
they're selling 18 000 tickets in
jacksonville and the industry hasn't
given them they sell so many tickets no
do you know what the saying used to be
when i was coming up in like the 90s
when and for that matter early 2000s so
if you had a tv show if you if you
if you were casting for a tv show yeah
okay and it was almost always all white
tv all white cast but if you had a black
cast member you always they would have
an ethnically thing do you know what the
saying was they were saying the saying
was to your point
do you want this person in your living
room every week is this the kind of
person that your family wants in their
living room that's why fresh prince blew
yeah
threatening you couldn't have and that
old way of thinking still exists it's a
saying that with some of those things
where somebody says it to you if you
don't know you're like yeah that's a
good ass right but
we're not watching to be friendly
sopranos change that the sopranos people
went wait a minute tony browner cheats
on his wife kills people he does all
kinds of [ __ ] and we can't get enough of
them that changed tv people started
going hold on that old thing of the
person has to be likable it was all you
if you wrote a tv show if you were on tv
you had to be likable and the actor had
to be likeable
like if i'm 85 south you know how much
money those boys are yeah
we know the podcast game we know touring
yeah look hollywood [ __ ] them like um
hopefully they don't have this weird
chip on there no they do not
they're
millions and millions upon millions of
dollars i got all the respect for you
let's say let's say whoever paramount
plus game of tv show they're going to
make less yeah
they're not dumb guys like i've talked
to dc about business back in the day mtv
tried to get both of us on a deal they
offered him way more money as they
should and he was like no i don't want
this so they're not dumb guys but
i also think it says something about the
industry that they haven't looked at
these guys and been like throw them
everything no they don't let them do
what they want to do
they don't know what to do with them
they have no idea can't you just say do
whatever you want figure it out
but my thing is on what so it's not like
see it you know agencies are trying to
figure out the podcast and you know all
that [ __ ] and they're like they're two
years behind me yeah so with them it's
like
yeah i guess you know what toss them
what a tv show i i mean back and then
they're writing for four hours a week
and then you know oh i don't know if
they would want to do it but i i would
think back in the day they used to have
development deals right i know you don't
do that anymore but if i had money for a
development deal those are the three
guys i go for right away yeah they
stopped doing [ __ ] those groups they
always got pregnant
every show wants a black audience yeah
and they're all getting these black guys
that are like i think this [ __ ]
is corny and i grew up in the suburbs
yeah so why would you not go to the
[ __ ] coolest funniest dudes in the
business right are they comics or they
stand up come on yo they're all stand up
dc stepped into stanford
he's a [ __ ] talented smart kid he
holds his own yeah and carlos is born
and bred santa chico born and bred stand
up these guys came up uh last comic
standing
he was like top seven and he hated every
second of it because he doesn't want to
perform with just white people yeah but
that guy can that guy can look where
he's going
somebody's talking about that with
chappelle until very recently
his his audience is all white yeah
this is really interesting like his his
audience was almost i mean i was i
remember back in again sorry to go so
back but i remember 93 and he was
getting up and doing stand-up and he
would be so high but it was all white
people who just you know it was
primarily where he made it i grew up in
the suburbs that's how i found out
chapel love chappelle before the
chappelle show i think chappelle shows
the crossover yeah yeah the moment for
him
maybe that's where the money was and now
the money's changing right so the money
used to be in white audiences right
because that's who went to movies that's
what went to tv show that's who was
spending money it seems advertising was
directed at white audiences yeah and all
of a sudden now finally they're like you
think still yeah still i think just uh
america is white it's white it's just a
white country but there's money
you look at these corporations like espn
or whoever that gets so woke and then
they only put black people on and their
ratings go
well 94 of all commercials now i think
they just did a thing 94 of the
commercials i think during the super
bowl had white black people like
primarily like it's sam tripley's joke
you got a white dude you got a black
woman they have a kid and the kid's
filming yeah you can't you can't do
black guy white woman because that's
more people are more sensitive
and again i wouldn't if the shows were
mainly white people i
didn't love it because it didn't work
out for me but i understood the basic
math of it the thing that people always
said the saying was it's show business
yeah the second half is business so i
could always compartmentalize and be
like alright fair it's business at the
end of the day what i can't understand
is where the ratings keep plummeting
you're not making money and then you're
forcing diversity and what they'll do
with indians is like let's make him
indian and gay let's make him indian and
he's afraid to go outside let's make an
indian and this thing so we can just
cram all the weird [ __ ] into one person
yeah and then we don't really have to be
as diverse and it's like dude just be
[ __ ] human beings yes but i think
what's dope is like the those 85 south
boys like they don't need any of them no
they don't need anything i mean really
no one does yeah there's no excuses now
yeah like dude get a camera figure out
your own staff 100
they're so acting they're so talented
yeah like jordan peterson yeah pitch him
on a tv show let me know how it goes for
you yeah he's making [ __ ] nine
million a month what are you gonna do
yeah he owns it all it's it's
subscription then he goes around the
country doing speaking engagements i
don't know how you can listen to that
[ __ ] accent for an hour straight
though jesus it's tough
i can't do it i could use it in bits
yeah yeah yeah yeah what is climate oh
right buddy because i can't tell me what
it is because i can't listen to this
voice for too long jesus [ __ ] christ
he's got a high voice but but i don't
know when people are going to stop
waiting for hollywood to come give them
the ticket to the ch chocolate factory i
think the like thing about rogan which
is the biggest show on the planet hands
down there's nobody bigger bigger than
legacy imagine if you would if you would
have went to
some network like this is my idea that
like get the [ __ ] yeah you talk for
three hours yeah so you pick a lane dude
we have democracy the internet
democratized all of it and it's cool and
i was thinking about rogan's life and i
was like that's the best life ever he
doesn't get followed by paparazzi
everywhere he goes he can he's getting
recognized everywhere but like he can
live a life and he's richer than every
a-list celebrity we've ever not anymore
but yeah yeah yeah
yeah now
well at least he's out of la so like
tmz's done he can't go that's what i'm
talking about that [ __ ] now i know his
life is i'm sure a pain in the ass yeah
but he he's like like will smith is
getting followed by cameras everywhere
everything yeah everything about his
personal life is out in the old dicaprio
like taking pictures in the house yeah i
don't know about that as much from rogan
no romeo he's richer than all of them
yes yep that's what that's the win
that's the move and he owns his [ __ ]
yeah
he doesn't own it well he can be his he
can also be himself like i don't think
you can be yourself as an actor a lot of
times the biggest problem is that we
used to have actors on and the problem
would be it it was just so bad because
they yeah
they were guarded of a persona there was
a mask you wear there's a persona you
have to like if you watch old they don't
let little think about ole miss
characters the whole time
terrible people [ __ ] johnny depp he
shows up like a pirate and he's just so
cool and he's smoking and there's a
whole thing and i'm like dude you don't
i don't
you're not really being you don't know
i'd like to know who you actually are it
doesn't work on podcasts no actors don't
get away the inside actor studios was
dope
yeah i guess that was the one well
how did you get done on bad boys too
will nobody but
actually that was always a small there
was a lot there was a lot of episodes
that i watched that i thought were very
very interesting i like that show and he
just ruined it
there's no criticism at all it's
literally just a big [ __ ] fest of the
celebrities well i don't know who you're
watching i i i've seen them all i'm a
fan of the show too but at the same time
it was just it's not a podcast
jack off the celebrity it's not a
podcast it's more like tell us about
that tell us how did you get in
character for joker no you're not wrong
that's not a weird question no that's
hey
how's that weird no it's not you're
weird his point is there's no there's no
dot there's no back and forth i would
think that's an interesting question i
can hear that question anyway no no no
no no hold on it's a good it's not a
show it's an excellent no he's good at
interviewing and it's very i love how
hard you're writing for james often yeah
i'm running hard i love that here's his
point no here's his point no he's great
but the point is is that shows not i'm
yeah he's saying in a real ideal world
it should have a lot of questions mainly
questions that are yo you're very dope
and then occasionally you should also be
like hey what happened with this yeah or
this movie bomb what was that what made
you make that decision hey will when you
did that earth show with your son and
ate all the [ __ ] did you feel some type
of way they won't even touch that movie
yeah like for example it's all scripted
and what happens i think in three hours
of conversation like so stephen tyler i
love him aerosmith [ __ ] lead singer
great but when you hear him talk with
rogan
you very quickly realize he's good at
kind of one thing you start trying to
get him interesting he doesn't know a
lot yeah that's interesting to me that
you so you don't know a lot yeah so you
so what what a podcast does it puts
people in a very human place where
they're talking
out of their zone they're not talking
about acting right you get to know them
you get to that's fair like we'd have
actors on it's different all they talk
about and i can i guess i think that's a
great show i would i know he's looking
at it like
when i watch the
eddie murphy uh
uh episode like
i'm an eddie murphy fan yeah and like to
hear
that world like it was inspiring 100
percent 100 what i mean like that's how
i feel like i look at it like a good
show but the stand-ups were always the
best
because you have to be three-dimensional
with your jokes you got to be
three-dimensional with acting too yeah
but stand-ups the whole thing is
basically robert had a good one
perspective you have to have your life
those experiences they have a
perspective you know like acting it's
just like
dude i i talk about relationships on the
stage but if i my relationship with my
wife but if i don't present three
dimensions of it if it's all oh she's a
pain in my ass i'm not funny i have to
also say the stupid things about me or
whatever and so you take that to an
interview and now you're talking about
your relationship and you have three
dimensions to it already actors do that
with one character and then they leave
it alone and they do that with another
character and then they leave they don't
do that with themselves yeah you know
what i mean and i guess you're right my
favorite ones were the ones of people
that who who were stand-ups and they
have layers though but yeah they haven't
been like
talked to you all day about it or like
yeah i think so he was pretty honest
about stuff he goes i think i think i
should have got an oscar for this
because that role was okay blah blah
blah
but he's a stand-up so he's he doesn't
care about the backlash that stuff but
like bradley cooper's on there and he
says anything like how
you dude you in the
hangover is
yeah yeah yeah
it's like it's all actors
that's fair yeah you know so i mean
again it's a good interview
podcasts have done is it's blown the
[ __ ] top off of the illusion that is
celebrity that that's what's [ __ ]
amazing about the rock says hold my bear
yeah that's like the sunday like
leonardo dicaprio the wrong like the
actual a-listers yeah don't subscribe to
our world yeah
they're like no we're out but that's a
hard exception but for the most part
well they've been in it since like yeah
yeah you know they've been but even the
rock has to keep up to an extent with
you know social media and yeah
but he's just he's not running i think
no yeah he don't know the rock is
awesome because he's got a sense of
humor the rock is just funny the rock is
kind of like a comic did you see him in
the super bowl he does the [ __ ] that
kind of he does a lot of different stuff
he's a smart [ __ ] guy he's smart guy
funny i think to get to that level will
smith the rock leo you got to be [ __ ]
smart you can't be a two-dimensional
person and their interviews are going to
be great the [ __ ] can play the
piano and the guitar and sing and did it
in wwe yeah you know and
so he's he's sucking him hard right now
but i feel you yeah he's fantastic oh
this is the [ __ ] you're talking about
the sucking up okay because he did go
bad on rogan but it's whatever yeah but
then he again he has to play that i
don't know if he went bad on it yeah i
don't think he wants that i don't i
don't agree with you i don't think he
went bad on him i think what he did is
he said i didn't i didn't hear that part
and so somebody said call them out on it
because i didn't hear that part that's a
little disturbing and and did not say a
little disturbance what he said he was
like i retract my statement saying that
he supported rogan bring him oh yeah he
completely i don't think he said i
retract my statement i don't know i
don't think he said that my thing is is
like why say anything at all though if
you're the rock like why are you
answering this random dude because he's
political he wants well you have to
hear don wenzel thanks so much for this
i hear you as well as everyone here 100
i was not aware of the n-word used prior
to my comments but now i've become
educated to complete narrative learning
learning more from me mahalo yeah i'm
i'm fine with that yeah i'm 100 fine
with that he walked the line and i have
to because he's here
that's not walking the line i agree with
that statement yeah that's what i'm
saying if you're that big
he didn't say what he could have said
which is i take it back he walked a line
in the sense of like that's as much as
he can show support so good for him
and i feel so sorry for him i don't care
how much money he has he has to walk
that line yes do you know politically
where the rock's at do you know i mean i
didn't serve it you have no idea no you
have no idea you have no clue he can't
give you his opinion right because if he
gives you an opinion he sells
the tickets over here yeah and this
other half [ __ ] with him he has to walk
that line trying to be the billion
dollar man for the movie it must be
exhausting but it works we can't be
yourself that's
terrible yeah it still sounds pretty fun
i don't know about that i think you're
right about that i think i think it's
very it must be exhausting to have to
because a certain time can only have so
many private planes you can only be in
so many movies jumping on [ __ ]
helicopters on fire now it's just live
for him he's like i can't say [ __ ] right
yeah but imagine do you think it's
bugging him oh yeah i do imagine you
just did it for a year made all the
money and then you're like hey [ __ ] all
you guys and then you win now that's not
how he works i think he wants to be
president and i think i think that
that's part of his life yeah that'd be a
nightmare for him well i don't think he
does it's the arnold schwarzenegger
model you know it's like i feel like
he's a guy you think he wants to be
president or he said that i i've heard
him still want to yeah wants to do that
i remember i was about to run from
political office i remember watching the
presidential debates in my homie michael
blasting the comic we're watching
blouse the best but it was barack and
romney i think and they're going at it
and then he just we're all watching and
then he just looks at tv goes why would
anybody want this
and i was like that's a good [ __ ]
dude
that life sucks like the smartest people
in our country aren't running for
president yeah they're like [ __ ] that
yeah you have to be just be sociopathic
yeah i think you're right about
completely i think you'd be very i think
all of us would be very surprised my
conjecture
very surprised at how
fun it isn't sometimes yeah oh i agree
with that yeah i think that heavy lies
the crown i think yes heavy lifestyle
look at john cena
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just kidding
taiwan's a country and then next you
know you speak in mandarin and yeah
i could magic in that coma okay you
wanted mandarin okay all right that was
an embarrassing moment for america oh
man we should not have to do that that's
just jon [ __ ] seen her brother walks
around in jean shorts you got to be
racially accepting jean shorts and knee
braces
and no shirts
he should be allowed to live in a
[ __ ] trailer park that's his life
dude that's his outfit let him match
that [ __ ] wait what was the problem
again with africa
because his movies do better in china
okay but if he says taiwan is a [ __ ]
country then china doesn't consider them
a country so
just so the history is that china
considers taiwan to be a part of china
but when shanghai
and his forces
left china they they had a battle when
they left china and founded taiwan as
sort of a dissident colony
that the the united states threw their
support behind it so taiwan became this
sort of capitalist country they did not
go communist shankarshek was not a
communist so so so now china has always
considered them to be taiwan to be part
of so
if you've seen that [ __ ] up you say
china if you say taiwan's a country and
you recognize it china went
[ __ ]
you're a billionaire over here you're
like you still have been if you do that
we're not playing your movie oh i sat
down that like he was doing this oh
like boom i was good what would you have
done huh
i don't know i'm not john cena i don't
know i don't know
honestly i think it's easier said than
done even with the rock i'm not saying
like i don't know
i'd like to think there's a number then
here's what's tricky it always gets
higher there is enough but
we've all heard the term but i hadn't
heard until my business friends started
saying [ __ ] you money and i was like oh
what is that and it's just the amount of
money that i don't ever need to do
anything i don't want to do what is that
number for you is john cena therefore
i don't know that's what i'm thinking
they came to johnson he's probably gonna
guarantee they came to john cena i think
the studio came to john cena and said
hey dude we have a major crisis the
reason that you make so much money and
we make so much money and the reason
that you're such a you command 20
million dollars a picture or whatever is
because
we can sell this we can pre-sell
anything you do to china i also
and then they go this is worth now if
you want to make a stand and not do it
cool you're going to lose 60 or 70 or
maybe 100 million dollars over your over
your lifetime is that cool and it might
affect everything you do well i would
i'd be more concerned and this is where
i could see myself caving i think maybe
i'm giving myself too much credit as a
good person is like not you you might be
fine what about the guys who just worked
on this movie and this is their first
movie and if it flops the whole studio
yeah everything yeah what about
everybody
that's the fourth lead he finally gets a
shot like dope yeah that might get me to
be like hi i'll suck china's dick a
little bit me too so my my buddy worked
with i don't know maybe about to say his
name but he was he's a big director and
he had tom cruise and they worked on a
[ __ ] script for one year yeah one
year and tom i mean i'm talking about
kind of every day yeah and tom cruise
wouldn't pull the trigger and i said
what the [ __ ] why doesn't he say yes you
guys are working on the script and he
said because if the minute he says yes
the minute he signs on to a movie
a thousand people
have a job a thousand people can pay
their mortgage or a thousand or more and
then
way more than that entire studio
is
is basically
a hundred million dollars richer yeah
yeah so so the the responsibility on his
shoulders the minute he's a lot and he
when he chooses a project he's got two
projects a year if he [ __ ] up and he
said no in the end after a year like he
couldn't do it yeah i was like [ __ ] dude
that's so much yeah i don't know that's
a lot of i don't know i don't know what
john cena's responsibilities are i don't
know what the rocks are yeah yeah
yeah i i think that's i think yeah yeah
like i would say that's what i'm saying
it's easy it's easy
for us to like you know say some [ __ ]
about him at the same time i'm like what
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] i don't
know what he's doing you have
responsibility for other people's lives
right like when you're responsible
there's a reason why i did it and i'm
sure it's not just that this movie's
going to bomb over i'm sure there's a
lot that goes on i'm looking at
brennan's rolex more and more and i'm
like this guy got to figure it out dude
i think john cena has nine of these no i
know but you that's what i'm saying you
get to say whatever the [ __ ] you want
to watch you walk around multiple of
these
ferraris
my cousin is a watch fanatic he like
cares about the movement so i'm
peripherally drawn in a bit like he
loves omega and he was like one i got a
speedy speed
and he was like if you get one omega get
the speedy i don't i had another omega
before that actually but he's not like
but uh schulte uh rogan hooked schultzy
up yeah yeah chelsea's becoming a big
watch guy too now but he's more in it
like you're in it like it's an
investment my cousin is like what moves
the best i want to keep all these i want
to sell them yeah and you've got a
[ __ ] great thing where it's like i'm
gonna wear the fly [ __ ] and i'm gonna
sell it and [ __ ] i don't know man
make money dude oh you know crime is in
there yeah right now right you're right
you're right don't say it come on yeah
come on you can't wear these beverly
hills get robbed yeah yeah my bigger
problem with the crime is the masks
why are you still doing the masks yeah
the one i take more crime on this mask
yes i agree that's that's
right
that's where i'm at right yeah yeah yeah
shoot each other
don't make me wear a mask though yeah
unless you agree the only mask should be
on the surgeon when i'm in the er having
gotten shot or the guy robbing the bank
i don't do you guys don't you feel like
we've lost all our freedom to what to
say i always feel like i'm on camera but
it's only here it's over here going l.a
yeah
i know and then and then [ __ ] you and
your masks la i think you [ __ ]
i just don't see an end to this pandemic
though but meanwhile everywhere else the
rest everybody else has
everybody's [ __ ] new york
to new york's credit and i don't like
defending new york but they didn't want
to do the masks the state governor put
down the mask mandate and then as soon
as they got overruled by the supreme
court they were like okay now you guys
are dead right there's no i think it's
done and there's some establishments
that are still like wearing a mask and i
hate those places yeah yeah yeah but
that's fine do you i just won't go in
there yeah don't that's yeah yes insane
private business fine you do what you
need to do i just won't still do it now
still in l.a but this yeah yeah so
i think they give some date on 2026
probably know march 15th like federally
the mass mandate is going to drop so
we'll see but it's weird
cares about china though no but i mean
in the olympics yeah anytime you're
compared to china on a government level
you're [ __ ] up i know
the olympics they're all wearing their
masks they they well that's because the
if the athletes get it they they've
worked four years for it and they're
[ __ ] yeah if i'm if i'm an olympic
athlete i'm wearing my mask everywhere
yeah they still make kids wear masks in
school that's wild to me it's good
why because there's no one more powerful
than the teachers union all the
politicians they have so much power
they're so scared of the teachers union
teachers like well we gotta protect
ourselves i am of the belief that kids
should never have to protect us i agree
never yeah that's what's funny have you
ever have you seen the video i think
it's vegas but there's a classroom and
the teacher goes they lift the mask
mandate you know how newsom and all
these [ __ ] creepy politicians like
kids actually don't mind it watch this
video of third graders when they go
there's no mask they go yeah they jump
out of their chairs and rip the masks
dude they're happier than they are the
last day of school it's crazy my kids
have been wearing masks for two years
now it's it did right oh do my kids
school send me a picture of my son i'm
like don't send me these [ __ ]
pictures dude i know people who meet
anybody i know people who were bernie
supporters had bernie fundraisers and
lived in l.a during the pandemic and
then moved to florida and then they were
like i don't agree with the right on a
lot of things but i'm probably gonna
vote republican for the rest of my life
oh bruh i hear that so what's this this
this is uh las vegas elementary school
burst out into chairs oh we don't have
to wear masks anymore
oh really you don't think kids are
excited about this
but new sim and
all right
one kid one wearing a mask in the first
place he was on his laptop like yeah i'm
gonna fly i don't look at the guy that's
not even jumping around democrats go no
kids don't mind it they're fine
but meanwhile their kids are in schools
where there's no math and i'm yo i'm
pro-vaccine i think the vaccine works i
also think if you don't get the vaccine
that's your right and if you die i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't feel bad for you i'm
not protecting you that's what you
wanted go ahead do whatever you want but
yeah
i'm pro i'm pro-vaccine uh 100 but i
just think yeah it's getting to the
point where you've got to make a choice
it's always in the name of humanity that
tyranny kind of finally i'm just curious
how long and it's so disheartening how
long is the la public gonna put up with
this
uh time you all are [ __ ] dude whoa
hold on i'm not you're not no no no you
no [ __ ] all y'all could kick my
ass most people could kick my ass but my
heart is bigger than my body is but it's
it's you have a lion heart yeah yeah to
me it's so disappointing how they just
like cause if you just were like nah
[ __ ] you knew some we're not wearing
masks do something the cops aren't
enforcing they've already said they're
not enforced yeah thank you so it's like
you know that nothing happens you just
stop when you walk into a coffee shop or
you do whatever they're like you gotta
they they're the ones i know the way
that yeah the way they think
they're
the ones because of they have the power
the the back of them knew something
right starbucks only cares about what
the government says in starbucks in new
york and the mass mandate was dropped
they said you don't have to wear it they
said if you're unvaccinated where oh my
gosh [ __ ] what about the restaurant we
have where the lady
snatched that yeah right up here she
snatched the mass vaccine thing she said
i'm not doing it i'm sick of it i'm out
i'm out she's not [ __ ] sick
she'd rip the sign off
please show your car please wear a mask
there's no more this it's over she was
just so over it i just don't i'm to me
it's so it's like so many sheep it's
insane
l.a is a but it's a dude it's an it's a
city built on people who just want to
make it at all costs so of course
they'll put up but it's also
it's insidious because it's just easier
it's like i can't i want to go and eat
and i i got my friends here it just it
becomes it's like [ __ ] all right here's
my vaccine card yeah i got a [ __ ]
mask i guess and i'll take it off the
minute i sit down
you don't want to be the only guy who's
like if we just band together
there's no it's over right it's like you
can go on as long as you let them keep
pushing what's going on with with with
canada and the truckers what's what's
happening with this [ __ ] they got the
the army reserve involved they're
shutting them down yo i don't know much
about anything yeah but i do know this
you know you you asked about punjabi my
wife is punjabi there's a lot of punjabi
truckers and i guarantee you a lot of
those [ __ ] aren't masked i mean
vaccinated i know them so if the if the
[ __ ] convoy was just like yo let's
just market these guys and have them be
the face of the protest all the liberal
[ __ ]
they're you're putting their two [ __ ]
they're at odds because they don't know
how to criticize minorities no matter
what right
they're [ __ ] punching down nonsense
and then all of a sudden they have this
other thing that they believe you
they're just done you neutral you've got
a bunch of sikhs who are orthodox
they're in their turbans and they just
in the truck nobody's gonna say dude i
promise you a lot of these [ __ ]
are not vexed i know these people i know
they're
wrestling them they're trying to stop
the rest of them and then also
like cnn's like they're racist they're
extremists
what oh man i just want to get there
i just they're literally
it makes sense again punjabis are often
they
trucking is like a trade trucking
farming these are like and they do
doctors and [ __ ] too for sure but
there's a lot that are truckers farmers
it's just a thing so i guarantee you and
there's a lot of punjabis in canada i
guarantee you there's a ton that are
truckers and a lot that probably aren't
vaccinated just [ __ ] make them the
face of it and i promise you all the
racist [ __ ] they what are they gonna do
yeah what are you gonna do yeah that's
such a good idea yeah [ __ ] that's that's
a good match what do you got dude all
right
here we go what's this current events
yep yeah that's my [ __ ] hero right
here dude
that's my lord and savior i love this
guy
elon musk recently had donated 5.7
billion dollars worth of tesla shares to
charity this is following a few months
ago he said that if the
world organization for i believe hunger
can prove that with six billion dollars
they could end world hunger he would
give it over they did not give him an
answer but he proceeded to go ahead and
sell that and he gave away that many
stocks here's what's dope yeah he did it
in november and then never said a word
and we're just finding out about that
because of sec filings
that's fire yeah so if you want to
criticize elon musk or capitalism you
let's see how well you do with charity
that's really dope i heard he used to
hang out at the store the comedy store
oh yeah i didn't know not like all the
time but he'd be there yeah i heard but
like before he was like you know yeah he
loves comedy oh wow yeah that's wild
you think he watches this podcast
i don't know
we might be too stupid i know right
here this is here so oh yeah this is the
football player stefan diggs allegedly
had two women in the same hotel on
different in different rooms on
different floors for valentine's day
yeah and the internet had put this
together because they saw two girls that
he was linked with posting that they
were in a specific hotel and they were
matching the rooms like wait i think
they're in the same place but how do
they know like can it be just two
separate girls like we had man like how
do they know it's both was diggs we had
michael irvin on the podcast and he said
this is what he did every week he just
had different girls in different rooms
i've talked to him but with michael
irving said that yeah yeah but were they
aware what are these great athlete of
all time
i'm a cowboy fan growing up he's got
great stories about what it was but hold
on how do we know that
they're both with stefan dicks
they were both linked and it's just
coincidence that he was at that hotel on
both of those women that he was linked
to were also there on that same day
just kind of tell us
another question how do we know they
don't they aren't aware that they're
both there oh i don't think anyone's
making a assumption that they don't know
they might know but they're saying that
just did that like he did that or they
didn't because the girls could have
known that they know how does this make
you feel as a woman yeah they have a
problem with this uh no i think to each
their own i mean i don't know their
situation what if these girls are into
it because i personally know a lot of
girls who are like oh i don't care if
he's like hooking up with him
i'm hooking up with other guys too it's
like whatever this is what evolution
wanted this guy should be spreading his
seed i probably should not i'm gonna do
it i'm gonna have kids i'm gonna have
kids with my life
i'm gonna have kids with my wife for
sure but i it's the humanity's not
stronger this guy should have all the
kids and they actually brought up a
video where somebody was interviewing a
bunch of vikings players asking what guy
on the team would you not want to date
your sister and everyone said stuff yeah
so this is the video what guy on this
team would you least like to date your
sister at least i should take my sister
diggs
he said that immediately
stefan dick
that's crazy
what the hell
you're starting to be the runaway
favorite for this nobody want me to do
this is it
great god
i'm actually a great guy that's what
every piece of [ __ ] guy says
you guys that don't think that you feel
differently about me yeah he just don't
know me well enough as well
all right who don't i wanna date my
sister the price thing like just because
he hooked up with so many chips ugly
yeah yeah that's what's going on you get
so many oh yeah it's probably the
biggest place
left and right yeah dude two black
queens what's wrong with that this guy's
doing it you know what i mean man
stay true i say yeah let him have i
don't think people realize you do but i
i think pro athletes some pro athletes
get so much female attention like it's
what do you mean you don't think people
really i think everybody knows that yeah
hey we really unlock the mystery of the
universe no right this guy should start
his own hog wait wait wait wait wait you
mean professional athletes get girls you
guys i don't think people realize
celebrities and athletes get tricks man
no i think i don't think i think some of
these guys like their their dms and
stuff must be out of [ __ ] you know
what you know i don't think anybody's
ever thought about that
that's the most obvious statement that's
ever been said
i'm gonna be real for a long time i
didn't think like
uh like that were married to their wives
and [ __ ] i didn't think they cheated let
me put it yeah let me put it this way
i don't respect a woman who dates an
athlete and thinks he's faithful you're
a [ __ ] hold
up you're a [ __ ]
i don't think i'm telling you i don't
think people realize like if you go if
an athlete who's got a high profile goes
to new york or l.a let's put it this way
i would suggest most people don't
realize the
volume and quality of of attention that
they get i feel like most likely yeah
i think they're like here's what i will
say it might be an older take i don't
know here's why that's in 1990
[Laughter]
let's put it this way there's a better
way to put it i don't think most people
like so i was in vegas with derek
cheater and some other people okay i'm
telling you at that table
i'm telling you
that women were being brought
to him
in line no they would have been
presented
yeah
unless you see it i didn't know here's
what i was until i saw it i went oh my
[ __ ] god i went to 40 40 club and
there was like a i obviously didn't get
him there's like a vip section chris
paul was there trey songz was there yeah
and the level of hotness i i didn't know
existed on earth yes we i i used to put
this in a bit you know how we rate girls
on a one to ten yes turns out there's a
ten to twenty yes they're just for
famous people
that i didn't know that's true but uh
that's what i mean yeah again i guess
what i'm saying is you don't unless you
if you want to judge anybody unless
you're a dude like that who has dealt
with that and seen what they deal with
with the 10 to 20 it's so [ __ ]
overwhelming it's crazy so my buddy sat
next to mike tyson and this was well
after he fought this is probably
ten years ago he called me and goes dude
i've never seen anything like it i've
never seen anything like it it was
before i think it was before the
hangover was even before like he would
got back as it should be if you date a
professional athlete or a rapper and you
expect him to be faithful you're the
dumbest [ __ ] that's ever existed
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i don't
respect you as a human come on some of
them might be
calm yo they might be but to expect it
yeah yeah if they are great for them
that's a superhero
how [ __ ] dare you dude
i'm a comic who's five seven hundred
fifty pounds i shouldn't cheat on my
beautiful wife uh god didn't give me the
tools to change
he made me to be faithful but you are
cute like a faithful man is cute
[ __ ] stefan diggs the good
looking adonis athlete of a man
god created him to [ __ ] everything so
you don't so you don't judge
i would say dumb [ __ ] how dare you
how dare you expect a guy like stefan
dicks to be faithful hypothetical [ __ ]
you would never judge lebron james or no
thank you i would judge savannah if she
thought he was faithful but she knows
thank you that's lebron [ __ ] james
dude right how dare you expect him to be
faithful i i did i actually thought he
did you're from a different world you
did huh did i expose him
i think we assume i don't know
i just think there are some men that
that that any woman including married
women including 80 year olds wants to
[ __ ] and they deal with that on a level
that i don't think anybody even
understands yeah you are that person yes
it's that crazy yes
but that's all fair yeah if you expect
faithfulness as a woman dating that
person how dare you yes and i think
athletes deal with it even more than
famous actors actually yes because
they're easier [ __ ] specifically
looking for their specimens dude they're
also better looking biologically
evolutionarily you want to [ __ ] that guy
yeah that's going to give me the best
seat yes
yes and you should let him i agree with
you i agree with you on that all right
you want lebron james over me yeah for
medium and wrinkle
100
so
over in norcal there is a 500 pound bear
called hank the tank that's breaking
into dozens of homes i think as of now
he's currently on a roll he broke into
20 homes
actually recurs to certain homes that
he's broken into so he's broken in a few
times at the same house that's an issue
but he's friendly though he doesn't eat
oh he doesn't [ __ ] anybody up no he
doesn't hurt that's kind of cool
hanging out until you're in the kitchen
he gets scared god
dude that's kind of a relief if a bear
was in my house i think my whole be
honest not that big of a pull
yeah yeah you would think right like
that's like a size really big
yeah i was actually thinking the same
thing
i mean that's probably 12 you know it's
not like
and also that doorway right that window
can't be that big that'd be struggle for
me to get through yeah
like this whole
i don't need to be negative but
like that
i would struggle to get through that i
agree with you no he broke down he broke
down another door yeah that's great the
next chin no that that's the to the
backyard so that's easy yeah i love this
bear yeah he's dope yeah he's just like
eating their berries and [ __ ] and then
he's dipping out bear he said hey i
think that's photoshop i don't think
that bear fit through that [ __ ]
window how about that
no i do you're logically it adds up
you're right logically
wow
and 500 pounds so the community is
[ __ ] terrified this has to be where
is it you say norcal uh they said norcal
but all these accounts are saying south
lake tahoe
oh they want to kill him now he
euthanized mm-hmm so they said yeah oh
they do what if you know south tahoe is
probably a bunch of rich white people
never met a black guy what if just some
black guy breaking in and they're so
racist they're like
some animals
yeah black bear emphasize on black
black what did you get
so the skier from finland is currently
resting because during the 50 kilometer
race there was a terrible storm that
they actually had to start an hour later
than scheduled and they cut down the
race from 50 kilometers to 30 because of
the cold this man had
frozen his penis
during this
course and i guess this isn't a rare
occurrence because it's happened to him
prior to this so he just constantly has
his penis frozen it's
he either has a [ __ ] python that like
[ __ ] freezes or it's so tiny where
it's easy to freeze yeah there's he's
not a middle one
it's either a long pants or tail and
it's freezing at the middle part there
or it's just real time and also he's not
wearing a lot of stuff down there maybe
oh god but i look at his face i'm i'm
thinking the ladder there i think he's
pretty small no he got he got a
micropenis face yeah sure yeah mustache
he got it so what sucks is this is your
dream so you got to just deal with the
frozen dick i think
like that's it that comes with the
territory hopefully we got a sponsorship
from proactive
holy [ __ ]
my man is miserable dude yeah it's a
tough goat
that's tough that bomb mustache he's
guys that's tough poor guy
but he what did he win he got he had a
map
i don't know i don't know they did not
they did not list it norway and china is
kicking our ass today you got a frozen
dick you better win country skiing yeah
which is you know i'm gonna go ahead and
say he did not win i feel like they
would have said something if he did yeah
oh that'd be the first thing guys guy
dick freezes
sacrifice his dick yeah there's nothing
we have no idea how if he finished
dude he got he should get some kind of
medal participation medal something
frozen dicks
[ __ ] 11 miles 12 frozen so you just
stalled that bad boy out i don't know
how that works well you don't you can't
wear a lot of clothing right so you
freeze yourself sean his dick probably
froze midway through the raisin he's
gotta also don't do that i gotta keep
going also don't do that sport though
yeah but also don't who cares nobody
watches and you make no money yeah
winter olympics is a wonderful wow do
you watch that i don't know in those
countries is it big yeah in norway i
think right so also bigs
i don't think so
soccer is big
i mean cross-country skiing is like all
right you know
if you're in vermont in this country
vermont and stuff well the the lot of
cross countries cross country ski teams
you don't see a colorado where did you
grow up yeah i grew up in mesa arizona
that's why
you guys didn't make the town how you
know a cross-country skier in a desert
no you know he uh
he lives out here okay but he's from
sweden okay but he's back home he's
actually back home in sweden right now
doing it wow yeah you're fascinating
dude he just does it because some things
about you are so blessed i thought
you're more interested he's the most
fascinating man on earth some things are
so black and some things are so white
you cut his veins and blink 182 comes
out
really no
all the small things he has an oasis
tattoo his tattoos are only bands
really he's in a punk band he's very
unique and very very special and smart
yeah all right fair enough i feel like
he's throwing smart just because he's
you're black right now
that's what he did huh
he's very funny
very smart
and he is
no he's always he's always said that no
i never used smart until i saw how
curious you were and how [ __ ]
interested you were in different ideas
yeah that's that's not that's rare yeah
no no i was [ __ ] like okay i go i go
[ __ ] you want to say that's rare for
your people i know a lot of people yeah
this has been racist 101 this has been a
good comment i don't know about the math
that's my oh yeah
yeah and his reaction to when the girl
was trying to take a picture and she
fell down and walked away
[Music]
but he he go you seem like oh [ __ ] but i
don't know no i didn't he just walked
here's a video he's actually hilarious
and then his wife helps her
she falls he goes oh [ __ ] and he walks
away
then the wife goes to help
but he comes back he comes back right
does he because i don't
see she fell off the stage and like
cracked her she was supposed to take a
picture and then she was walking
backwards and a lot of times when you're
on stage you can't tell her
i heard he went back yeah he went back
but people were like staffordshire yeah
they're giving him credit he's got [ __ ]
so he has him and his he's also not a
responsible doctor so whatever you want
he paid her he paid the bill they said
that him and the rams
they paid for the hospital bills and
also like her camera equipment because
she damaged your camera equipment yeah
yeah
also don't fall off stage
and then like oh that's awesome i like
how they made him out to be like a
[ __ ] monster like european there's
like he was like i'm not a doctor he's a
drunk attitude
already yeah
oh [ __ ] he just kept going yeah i don't
know i think he's a racist
it's funny you say that brian because
apparently people started digging
through this girl's social media the
girl that fell she's racist and they
found like old like she used n-word
quite a bit for i don't know and twitter
listen
let me say let me say something as a
black person
we have assumed that
everybody has [ __ ] said the n word
at one point i don't use it i know you i
don't know i know but
we we assume that everybody is at least
are you the guy
no i just i just get quiet all of a
sudden you're like
in middle school i was rapping along i
said the word he's like don't ever say
that word and i was like
what and he was like don't ever and i
was like okay all right you know him
i grew up at a time when people who are
indian mexican i heard them say it all
the time yeah all my important most of
my important reasons in new york city
use it yeah puerto ricans use it just as
much as black people do indian friends
will use it and then they'll be like my
black friends let me say and i'm like
yeah but what about a black stranger you
think they'll let you say it yes you
might be in that circle yeah yeah this
is one thing
man yeah
that's one thing i always say and i only
say this i'm only speaking for myself
okay
i don't get mad about the word
you know i don't yeah because i'm not i
don't i don't want to take it any
further than what it is but you don't
have anything but everybody ends like
calling you right no i don't but when
people have said it i go hey you're
lucky you're around me and i was like i
was like if another black person was
right you're in trouble you're going to
be in trouble because they don't
and they kind of and they stop and they
stop saying it yeah because they're like
oh [ __ ] like yeah i'm like listen i'm
not going to get mad yeah i'm not going
to do anything with you that's a high
stakes for all of the crapsticks that's
a [ __ ] there's also no need for it
but yeah yeah does it enhance your life
i don't yeah also i i never wanted to
use it because i don't wanna hurt
anybody's [ __ ] feelings i don't yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know
and i say i'm not i don't speak for
every black person but i say for me
you know i feel how i feel anyway but
why were you staring at me
what was he about to say what you
lingered on my face
and i know what's going on and i want to
stop everything because i can just
that this [ __ ] i'm talking and i
watch him he's a witness i had a joke
and you know i had a joke
i know he's doing this and as i'm
talking he's going like this
and he's not listening to me he's
looking at my face that's how well i
know him and i'm like no i know it's
going to be there's an old joke
it's too much well you were going to say
what about you
you've really grown because your family
owned slaves back in the day
[Laughter]
it was too much it was age enslaved
so funny how well i know this
[ __ ] we know each other so well
like it's just so funny how when you've
been together for that look i was like
save it for later man anyway
this whole podcast been race driven so
that's the other
i'm glad that we don't hang out because
if there's ever a sensitive topic and
somebody
is
you can't make fun of them and they show
up if you if you even look at me wrong
i'm gonna start laughing we've lost
deals because of it
so we kind of discussed this last week
about bob sagat's family so they
they got a temporary block for the
release of his records of how he passed
away and everything else i feel like his
family knows something that we don't
know why i'm like super curious about
the family yeah you know you heard all
the facts i know it's a blunt head
trauma right like that but the doctor
who uh
did the autism autopsy said it would
have to take a baseball bat to cause
those fractures on the front and back or
he fell out of a 30-story building whoa
so it makes no sense yeah i wonder if
it's um i feel like he was he was taking
blood thinners for sure but did he
i mean why yeah
i don't know i don't want blood
vendors have to do blood thinners have
to do a blood loss right but not the
amount of autoimmunity
so when you have when you take blood
thinners though you are more likely to
bleed internally right right no but but
with the fractures on the skull is what
i'm like and when a doctor who's like
has no skin the game is like i've only
seen this damage if someone hit the
person in the front in the back with a
baseball bat or foul
30-story building when they go well he
fell in the bathtub and then laid down
like that that worked for me yeah
cold case is way too much is it possible
though that he somehow again i keep
thinking did he fall backwards
hit his head with that much force and
then somehow crawl himself to bed and
but then
to fracture the orbital in the front is
so tough it's so [ __ ] tough he's the
back in front he's our epstein comedians
epstein yeah like i don't buy a single
[ __ ] bit i don't think anybody's ever
getting that how about jolene maxwell
just lane maxwell the the gay guy that
they were implicating he just committed
yeah there were no
like if you notice it's not getting a
lot of traction but a lot of these child
and sex trafficking places in florida
and all over again shut down nobody
thinks she's just ratting all this out
so i think they're going to do all that
they don't want to kill any information
that can get her a letter sentence with
all these powerful men or no well she
released that little black book and
noticed it got released but they blacked
out a lot of the names and they think
because a lot of those names are still
government officials still working today
so they don't want to get it out but but
but yeah i just think that was a clearly
uh it was hooker island and then they
got younger girls i don't know if i call
him hooker island but yeah well a lot of
those women that were brought there were
being paid i'd call it predator island
bro yeah
a lot of them were being paid but then i
think what happened was there were
certain dudes like epstein
according to the testimony and i haven't
followed too closely that we're like
okay that's cool there were also men
that wanted 15 year olds yeah 14 and 15
year olds but i heard i think there's
that i think that then a lot of it was
these women made a look the older and
they bring these high profile names
there yes they're like dude she's into
you you know that whatever you're not
checking they do it yeah they're
assuming
so then they film it and they go hey
bubba the last time it's fun right we've
recorded all of it so unless you pass
these agendas unless you play ball
you're [ __ ] yeah so then everyone's
like [ __ ] but you know i you and i know
a lawyer who is involved in this and
you know prince andrew so he he had sex
with this 17 year old which was actually
legal in new york at the time right okay
so that was it was not a crime it was
actually within that and he was like 41
or something like that but he gets there
there's no doubt that that dude was
going there and and having a good time
oh he was there
yeah yeah yeah but there's no confusion
but you really wonder if again is it was
it that which i can believe like was it
a some kind of an operation or was it
just that this [ __ ] dude epstein
was a pervert
we knew he could get to powerful men and
you know why
yeah and you just have a bunch of girls
i don't know i i think it's a mixture of
yeah i think i think somebody [ __ ]
over like made sure he had dirt on him
right and then some if you're friends
with homeboy right you know what he's
into yes and you go the island you know
what i'm saying right yeah you're
probably into it but most of the women
most of the women from what i've seen
were like
in their 20s
and professionals they were brought
there and they knew what was that well a
lot of me groomed though too like they
started with like a massage and i said i
know it's on payroll yeah [ __ ] sure i
don't know enough of this story i don't
have this i actually don't even know i
was like yeah but but it doesn't
surprise me that really powerful wealthy
men that there's a guy goes dude got a
private jet let's go to my island i
bring girls in
okay
that's guaranteed okay so who is the
latest who is this gay dude 30 times
what's that you said a gay dude killed
he was his handler yeah he he one of the
handlers get the chicks
like him kind of crazy you can bring it
up and i'll fill you in yeah i felt
pretty
closely so what's your take on the whole
thing i mean dude it's so toxic but that
guy was a liaison and he was part of a
modeling agency and he would help
recruit models
okay and he was also [ __ ] rainbows so
you know he's a gay gay guy killed
himself guillain maxwell that's right
that's the way he's searching
the best
people
he's very good at audio but when it
comes to google
yeah so what's like the issue yeah what
did you guys say dang it
uh first time
in her name
no you don't bother your promises her
name like she she's such a let me look
it up yes please
did they find were some of these girls
as young as 14 is that true 14 15.
wow
how do you spell sauger's name i got it
i'm pulling up the pose right now uh
john luke brunell the modeling agent
accused of supplying underage girls to
jeffrey epstein was found dead in his uh
saturday prison cell in paris so he
would feed them to absolutely john with
his death like
that jazlyn maxwell dude she would find
a girl in palm beach they'd go the mall
that's the attractive girl she like hey
i think you could be a model blah blah
blah don't type in her name
i don't think his name's right um
he was he was just a gay dude who
and the model agency would feed the
girls into epstein yep there it is
that's it
this stuff goes on and like we talked
about this in brunei
that's a different guy that's uh it's
all right we got the just division
he'd filter girls into them he commits
suicide there's a whole bunch of this
[ __ ] that goes on where like right now i
mean it's always gone on we know there
are girls that in l.a that make a lot of
money going to dubai going to are you
talking about
yeah like when they do the instagram
that's different
and then i would text like hey how's
dubai so it's so cool but then she had
like this she'd like oh i'm actually
here for the cell phone thing i'm
launching this new cell phone like oh
right on right on
and then she'd come back with all this
money i'm like man she's selling a [ __ ]
ton of cell phones like every two months
dude some sheet just [ __ ] down her
throat giving her [ __ ] 50 grand every
three months oh jesus christ
they call them toilet girls well i
remember
the same thing this girl i dated i
thought we were dating literally great
we were dating and she went to
[ __ ] i think it was brunei or to
bahrain and she told me that she was
doing she was importing furniture
from everybody it's always
my mom they were in the middle east at
the time my mother goes
she goes
bali to bahrain
she's doing that i go yeah she goes that
doesn't make any sense and i started
adding and it was big look at the phone
calls only [ __ ] bad connection i was
like what do you what are you but
they're so hot yeah that makes sense
yeah and then my one this one girl said
she's turning tricks you [ __ ]
and she came back and tried to get back
together with me i was like ah [ __ ] i
don't know man
yeah if ever you're dating a girl and
you see her on a yacht and there's
nobody else in the picture trust me papa
there's somebody else
yeah yeah yeah to get that picture on
there
who took it if you see a girl and she's
only instagram famous and she's on a
private plane trust me that's not her
playing she didn't work for her she's
she's doing something strange
entrepreneur she's not interested
in frequent flyer mouse you feel me and
you know what it wouldn't bother me i do
you girl hey
wait real quick question how do i pee
i'm about to piss my [ __ ] pants off
are we almost done should we
should we dip dip out on that
mark no i don't know if it's a rogan i
don't know what you're gonna bring up
what is it check out this little bad ear
here
it's the first ever down syndrome
victoria oh hell yeah yeah diversity
hell yeah i don't want to ruin faheem's
joke here's such a funny joke about this
all right well that's it that's that's
all right
god bless diversity
yeah we're doing it uh where were you
are you where are you going to be yeah
we're going to be yeah i'm going to be
uh irvine let me pull up some days i'm
going to drops tonight first of all your
special is is um
it's about 1.4 million views on youtube
right now it's one of the best specials
you will see in a long ass thank you so
much for watching i can't wait time uh
i'm 20 minutes of [ __ ] fury
i'm not done i'm trying to drop
something else soon so yeah keep an eye
out but so you have irvine on the 23rd
yep ontario california the 24th la i'm
gonna be it's already sold out but
dynasty typewriter on the 25th maybe i
could squeeze anybody wants to come let
me know maybe squeeze you in uh san
antonio march 18th through 20th tampa
april 8th through 9th and then toronto
i'm doing my first theater show at the
royal uh april 22nd and 23rd
oh gosh you're doing the damn thing man
well we love you here love you guys man
thank you yes you're one of my favorites
i tried to correct you and you kept
calling me oshkosh and i legit i was
like yo god wants our destiny is for him
to call me out
that's it that's what we have speech
[Laughter]
wednesday i love you dude oshkosh uh
wednesday night shopping friends we got
dalia callan chappelle jeff dye once you
only 8 pm
that's at the hollywood improv and then
sacramento is this thursday friday
saturday sacramento california nashville
just went on sale march 10th through the
12th at zany's then i close march with
chicago illinois march 24th through 26th
tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com also the calabasas fight
club merch drops tuesday that's tomorrow
10 a.m oops grenade drops at
thickboy.com get you some uh appleton
wisconsin skyline comedy club uh i'll be
there march third at the fifth jason
ellis coming along for the ride alice
he's amazing i saw him do it i was so
impressed he's a nice guy so [ __ ]
impressive he's so impressed
so he's going to be he's going to be
opening up uh phoenix arizona uh stand
up live march 11th to the 13th
louisville kentucky the comedy club
jason ellis again and myself march 17th
through the 19th then miami florida
miami are you on the you're on the road
every single week yes i am all right
this weekend kansas city
uh february 25th and 26th the comedy
club of kansas city march 10th through
the 12th the blue room comedy club in
springfield missouri uh april 8th and
april 9th salt lake city utah and
wiseguys comedy club boom let me know
how blue room is in springfield okay
yeah yeah i saw that you're doing it too
yeah yeah dude we love you the best you
guys thank you for having me